I was six my babysitter was murdered and  they never caught him justice was done  wanna play they kept the murders were  real Chuckie liver was that's right he  was a fantasy a devolution are you  feeling better now I don't blame you for  being afraid I was very ill Chucky told  me he's coming for you it's important  that we all explore it together as a  group I think I have something that will  help whoa all right  I'm Chucky wanna play first I'll kill  each and every one of you the most  horrible ways you can imagine and then  he'll kill me too are you afraid of the  truth  terrified you should be too night-night  and they call me sick wait a minute  there's two of them  a 2000 ever goes out of style  [Music]  you